[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
because the titties out she oh she
opened it up yeah you stretched the
collar
no it was like a loose like you know all
sorts of responsible woman right here
you don't know
this is i understand everything right
now like yeah like i hadn't before yeah
like the level of responsibility that
while you're talking about this girl
that you
may have had sex with yeah she's going
not what a [ __ ] for [ __ ] you the
first night she's going who stretches
the collar
like that girl is trash like you're
stretching your shirt that's like next
level i'm also offended by you saying i
may have had sex with her i don't know
i'm telling you i did well now you're
telling me but i'm not gonna put that on
you okay but i'm telling you that i did
okay because i'm a closer that's what
you oh all right were you laying up
so a titty was out right and went for
the titty guy sucked that right and then
so she started living at my house no
yeah for like a week oh yeah yeah she
wouldn't leave okay you mean and we were
just on the kitchen table all kinds of
stuff right yeah it was a great and then
um
about the seventh day in um we were at a
restaurant okay and i had a comic call
me
and go um yo dude that girl you're
hanging out with uh-oh don't bring her
to the club uh-oh and i go
why
he goes because i'm bringing my
girlfriend
right and i'm like why does that matter
why would that mean why would that
matter right yeah bro we're all [ __ ]
that girl so she was getting rinsed yeah
which is interesting yes just so then
rinse we're at dinner and i i get off
the phone with my friend oh yeah right
and i turned to her oh god they go um
are you getting ready are you being
rinsed by other comics yeah right and
she goes are you getting your fanny
rinse right and i go um oh can you tell
me who right she goes you have a pen and
a piece of paper no
yeah
right she started like you know i mean
it was like the dead sea scrolls it was
just like you know i mean she had a
unravel yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was like you know i
mean the list open micros i mean
you mean new york comics midwest comics
you know what i mean open mic yeah it
was like those insulting
i know and i looked at her and i go we
can't do this yeah and you know what the
most insulting thing is what
so a couple years later oh god
and he mentions her name
because do you know so and so
i go yeah
and i go did you he goes did you
and i go yeah and then two days later he
comes back up to me and he goes yeah
i'm seeing her i asked her she never did
with you
she didn't
she admitted
to
the dead sea scrolls
right 50 000 names right but she [ __ ]
left she she denied
she [ __ ] denied it wow that's
disrespectful you should be able to me
to her
that's what they say on the streets that
bobby lee
is doing extra [ __ ] yeah right but guess
what
do you know why
because kalila
one day four years ago goes i'm going to
uh guitar center to get podcast
equipment we're going to do one why is
she talking like that yeah yeah and i go
really no one's going to run time
no one's going to give up
she could barely open her mouth it was
stuck together
put your legs in guitars
so then
you know completely
this is just caked together
and she has to get podcast equipment
they're looking at her like you're going
to talk
anybody
i almost [ __ ] a little person that
worked at cpk i just got hard i love i
love watching little person porn you
almost [ __ ] a little person who worked
at cpk yeah he was like
he was a friend of of my my best friend
we were like 20. all i'm imagining is
him trying to get the pizzas out of the
oven
like operating a boom mic
or like putting the like there's a
counter here putting the pepperonis
[Music]
when i went last night to first of all
santino
called me today and i go he was singing
on the phone
he goes
you know how the white dudes they did
the pups
you know he was doing that wipe and i
hung up on him and then he called me up
again i hung up and then he goes your
[ __ ] [ __ ] and like
so then i go i go why in a good mood he
goes um i just you know i had lunch with
you sunday i'm excited about art thing
and last night dude i had
the best
main room show i'd ever seen it was
electric dude
i wish you were a part of it it was
so good
and i go who was on it and he goes
sand i lied that i didn't i wasn't there
um i didn't watch you
i got caught in a [ __ ] slide right
here man
oh my god i got caught in a lie
he's been trying not to lie as much too
i wasn't even gonna catch on to that i
wasn't gonna catch on to it either i
just realized i could have just kept
going
so anyway he goes uh it was the best
manor show ever the stupidest [ __ ] right
give a [ __ ] if
[Laughter]
but the lie is so arrogant because it's
like he needs to know that i was there
like the lion the lie serves you not me
right
god go on so um
[Laughter]
i love it
those lies are for the other person
right like most lives most
dude those lies are like no you look
skinny in that outfit or something like
that right because you're concerned
about them but your your lie was like
man he'd be heartbroken if i didn't
watch that
i used to live work at a coffee shop
with a dwarf
and he used to [ __ ] get mad [ __ ]
really yeah he was also like a punk rock
dwarf
oh that's a stupid tattoos to the wrist
but it's like one or two
yeah yeah yeah he had one tattoo of the
skull throughout his whole body
or a little garden snake that just goes
around the boat
yeah what do they do what do they do
besides listen you complain
my manager
this weekend said
you have to show up today
at noon for this netflix animated show
i'm doing right yeah so i go okay i wake
up at 11 and she calls me well i told
you 11 and you insisted nude i know
because she i she said noon
she [ __ ] said noon man oh she [ __ ]
up right so she had one job which was to
tell you tell me 11. yeah right one job
right i show up dude these mind-boggling
you're just mind-boggling 30 people in a
room they act like they're busy right
right
right like what are you busy doing you
don't do anything you can't be busy if
you don't do anything right like what
are you did you build something what are
you busy with but did you take anything
and then did you do that that's an
activity
that's an action i took this and i put
it here this is not busy you have to be
there at 12. that's not big oh my god
my day is so stressful right why is dr i
had to tell someone to be somewhere yeah
yeah
that's exactly i i got into rage and
then check this out she goes you know
what she says she goes
it's gonna be no big deal bob they're
fine so i show up there and they're all
sitting there 30 people in a room yeah
just i look through the window and
they're just
oh [ __ ] right oh so i'm wasting people's
time
valuable [ __ ] time and then i go in
there and they're like good to see you
they're being friendly i'm a nice guy
right um but they reminded me
14 times
to be there tomorrow at [ __ ] 10. well
now it's 10.
yeah
no they did they go because because i
was late today yeah they think now i'm
late guy
they think that now i'm mr irresponsible
so that they remind me 15 times and i'm
never late mm-hmm i always show up right
yeah so um and i told her today when i
walked out i go i don't know i mean
she i can get my own plane tickets
dude
can you
you can do it
i came on an elevator button once oh
yeah oh god i'm sorry what
i i came on an elevator i never told
this you were jerking off no okay
so i was
at a club yeah any many many years ago
even clubbing babe no at a comedy club
oh i was performing okay and i made out
with a girl
in the elevator okay right
coming down okay she was leaving
and as the elevator closed i jerked off
onto the [ __ ] buttons of the phone i
mean i love that
i love that i feel bad for whoever was
gonna press i might [ __ ] with vietnam i
don't know maybe you know i might [ __ ]
with it too yeah i'll go with you no
i've never been there let's do it saigon
bro saigon i'm being real let's go i'm a
hundred percent a bunch of comics like
me santino you come up with other guys
it'll be fine bro dude we'll get into a
show crew we will we'll do one show only
one
[ __ ] not two men not too many yeah
20 people show up
but for real dude like i don't know
that's the show i want to see live off
grid but the three of you living in in
vietnam for six months
when i was in thailand yeah in in
if you're thai god bless you and take
care yeah i love you yeah but um you
know if you're like oh
i mean if you if you like boy [ __ ] go
to thailand but my point is is that uh
dude that's another thing about that
part of the world what uh the asian
women
don't put close to the effort in that
the asian men do
or
like
scooby doo
no like when i when i saw the i mean
they were malaysian thai boys right or
malay boys
but uh but they were like the makeup and
all that kind of [ __ ] they were really
like sexing themselves up yeah and then
the regular like malay the malaysian
women they were like [ __ ] uh
yeah it's like put some effort in and
then we won't [ __ ] these guys
get some blush or a [ __ ] lip liner or
something like that these girls weren't
even doing [ __ ] and i totally understood
it dude i'm being serious i got it yeah
yeah i got it
they were going for it did you know in
thailand yeah
if
you're watching a movie okay they do a
10 minute montage
of the king
and you have to stand
during it during it so everyone's
standing i stood you know what i did
though
so you know
i did the noise right and um another
thing is that's 6 p.m at 6 00 p.m if
you're in a park they have these
gigantic speakers and when the music
comes on you have to freeze
hey that's like in the philippines
though when the did we do a prayer every
6 p.m yeah anywhere if you're in a
grocery store or whatever everyone stops
and then you do um you do a prayer
because it's a very catholic nation but
you know what i did
i froze for extra 30 minutes
sitting there yeah so i did
for 30 extra minutes people are walking
around me
[ __ ] bro you guys have embraced me more
than the new york scene has embraced me
wow really 100
west coast embraced me way before new
york that's so strange why is that
um i kind of like carved my own path in
new york like i didn't like do like the
traditional like uh i wasn't like
hitting the mics with a lot of people
and i wasn't like
for lack of a better term like really
kind of like hanging around maybe the
seller and like
um i don't want to say kiss and ass of
the ogs but like uh i just didn't feel
like that was the best use of my time
like i thought the best use of my time
was like getting on stage as much as i
possibly could and being as funny as i
possibly could you know and like that's
what my main focus was and i wasn't like
trying to like cozy up to anybody to
like open for them and maybe that was
interpreted as like
not
you know paying the respects or
something like that but that's never
what it was it was like i know what the
[ __ ] i want to do i know how to get i
can get better at comedy by working on
comedy not by telling this comic how
amazing his set was
does that make sense yeah but i but you
know for me um
my opinion about somebody is you know i
look at the work
okay so it's like you know when i i
remember when i first met you i don't
know if i said this the last time but i
didn't know who the [ __ ] you were right
yeah i had heard your name because i
knew that you were on the list because
we were doing that show together yeah
but it couldn't put a name to the face
so you were leaning against this like
pole yeah right and you go hey i'm
andrew yeah and what i wanted to say i
didn't say it i don't give a [ __ ] i love
it right
that's what i wanted to say yeah but i
go like oh nice to meet you andrew or
whatever of this [ __ ] white guy right
right that's when i first met you that's
what i got from you did you have a
really good childhood i think you have a
childhood unbelievable it's
unbelievable my parents are incredible
yeah my parents are absolutely you're
very actualized and you really have a
lot of the things that neither he or i
have what does actualize mean act like
you
you you can get there and you can rally
for yourself and you have that belief in
your own power yeah we're we're
spineless little um
um kind of scared of our own um
strengths
i don't believe we're finally scoops
i don't know i i i just i hope we can
get back to it man
i know i'm sorry i'm so sorry it's so
rude what happened you got a call oh you
don't know how to turn your own i silent
okay
an hour after
well you should've said it the first
time it happened i did i kept looking at
you but my eyes are not visible
that's your fault that's your badge i
have laser eyes i i i'm so sorry i just
turned it off another thing from the
duplex oh god oh god i hate him
so much so we're doing it tuesday
oh my gosh i should text yeah let's do
it you know what he does when you know
he does this we have uh my 19 year old
niece from the philippines lives with us
she doesn't give a [ __ ] about anything
but puppies and anime love it but he
wants her to respect him so he goes to
her room every night anytime he gets
let's say a text from the duploss
brothers
he'll google them get the picture out
get their credits like do you know that
i'm working with them oh no i don't do
that yeah i don't do that
[Music]
it's a dark place
[Music]